Jacob is with Acin Idaho hi Jacob
welcome for the Dave Ramsey show hello
sir how are you better than I deserve
what's up I have a question I got a auto
loan through a credit union a for
thirteen thousand we got a lower
interest rate from credit union B once
credit union B sent the check into the
first Credit Union I went and closed the
account they reopened the account and
made a deposit and they sent a letter to
our home saying that it was for gap
insurance so my wife went in closed the
account withdrew the money they just
called us and said that that deposit was
made in error and so we have to pay it
back or they're going to send us to
collections if we don't start paying it
back to them I know that morally I have
you know because of my relationship with
the Lord I have a moral obligation to
pay it back but I asked her why they
opened by they reopen the account in the
first place is that common practice as
far as your understanding because there
we didn't find anything that says they
can reopen it and then I asked for a
policy if they can email me or send me a
policy that states that they could and
she didn't know and she said she's been
working there for 18 years so I'm not
sure where that stand illegally if they
have the right to do that so I'm just
kind of it's kind of frustrating because
it caught us off guard I barely started
listening to the podcast of the Dave
Ramsey show and this thing caught us
caught me off guard so I'm known or you
have gap insurance why do you why are
you not do a refund for the gap
insurance they just they sent the the
letters to my wife and I'm my you know
financial understanding is very limited
I'm just I get scared of when my wife
start to talk about money and all that
but okay and I think the two of you
should take a minute how much money is
involved here it's what we owe what they
posited was like 682 dollars okay so
it's worth the trouble to a understand
what happened here and be argue about it
okay
so can they reopen the account I don't
know I'm not a lawyer they probably can
probably the original account allowed
them to do that and by the way very few
people gripe about someone opening an
account and giving them money which is
what happened here except that now they
want it back right so thing one is I
want to understand you and your wife
need to understand and go sit down with
the manager at the credit union you know
you can be calm and just go help me
understand you need you every other
obligation to show me what happened here
do you know what gap insurance is Jacob
no ok gap insurance is insurance on the
car that pays the difference in the
value of the car and the loan because
typically you owe more on the car than
it's worth and so you said was a $13,000
loan let's say the car was worth just as
an example $10,000 but you had a $13,000
loan your car insurance would only pay
$10,000 because the car is only worth
10,000 if it got totaled gap insurance
would pay the other 3,000 and lenders
generally require that you take gap
insurance to protect them if you've if
you're upside-down if you owe more on
the car then it's worth it covers the
difference you understand okay so it
covers that gap the gap between what you
owe and what the car is worth now what
happened was you closed out your gap
insurance early you had bought a mount
you bought a policy for the life of the
loan but the loan ended early because
you refinanced and so you would do a
refund on your gap insurance what I
don't understand is where the rest of
the money went because if it wasn't 688
dollars as a refund on the gap insurance
what was it where's-where's
my refund for my gap insurance well and
maybe it wasn't 688 maybe it was you
know less than that or whatever I don't
know what they gave you I want to know
how they calculated the 688 and where
they made this mistake now if you
prepaid the gap insurance for the entire
policy you would be due a refund if you
were paying it monthly you would not be
due a refund and you don't know so
you're not to go in there and learn why
it is that you aren't do you this refund
I'm kind of thinking you might be I
don't know right they need to explain to
you why where your gap insurance refund
went since they don't want you to keep
it yeah once you understand that then
then you can work out some kind of a
program with them to repay it because as
you said morally and for that matter
legally if they gave you money you
weren't do you you're gonna have to give
it back but I need to understand how
this mistake was made and what the
mistake is based on and where did my gap
insurance refund go since you're saying
I don't get to keep it you follow me
here yeah this can be a very calm
conversation we're not we're not cussing
at people or yelling at people or
something like that you're sitting down
with a branch manager going dude you
want 688 bucks you got to explain the
paper trail to me and my wife to where
we both understand it and then once we
understand it if it's the same
conclusion then we will work out a deal
as a matter of fact since they screwed
this up they ought to eat some of it
morally yeah but they probably won't
their credit union so you know try but
try and go understand if you actually
owe the 688 how much of it can you pay I
mean can you pay 300 a month for a
couple months and be done with it no we
can probably pay a hundred a hundred
where yeah we're not doing so well
financially where did that money go when
you got it we were stupid with money and
so we probably spent it going out to eat
or buying
dad how long ago was I hold no value
this was back in November okay and they
barely reached out to us a couple weeks
ago okay well you understand the program
then you're you and your wife we're
going to sit down in for in-person with
the branch manager and they need to
explain all of this to you where you
grasp it once you grasp it then you will
know how to put together a payment plan
and give them their money back and in
the meantime this also outlines for you
how important it is that you guys get
your financial stuff moving because 600
bucks should not be a crisis for you
agreed yes sir okay so are you guys on
some kind of a program are you starting
to work our stuff no we I've just been
listening to your podcast and I heard
you say something it was you have to get
honest with the man in the mirror and
and that's what I did I just had a
repent to the Lord for being a bad
steward and I just started thinking
about my kids in the future and so I
just want to I want to get it in order
so good that's where we're at right now
okay well I'll send you a copy of our
book the Total Money Makeover which has
helped millions of people become good
stewards start to manage God's money
God's Way for God's glory and we'll show
you not only how to get on a budget get
out of debt and download the every
dollar app it's free it'll help you get
things going to hold on Kelly I'll pick
up and we'll get you signed up for that